all stars to is upon us yes
yeah beauty get up in this all-star gear
how much fun is it to bring all those
girls back they are true about all stars
there's so much fun in such
professionals and they know how to
compete and win that's why they were
asked to come back and again we have
this this switcheroonie and in the way
that we play the game this time because
the girls actually eliminate each other
I don't decide who goes the girls decide
who goes are you happy to give up that
power or is it a little no I was very
happy to give power up because these
kids have already proven themselves and
they've made it through the hard yards
so what better way to reward them than
to give them the power to chop to chop a
girl Shante you stay
we've also flipped the lip-synch on its
head because now the top two queens are
battling yeah the top two girls of the
challenge get to lip-synch for their
legacy and the girl who wins that
lip-synch then decide which girl up the
bottom goes home now we also have a
season 9 is in the pipeline yeah yeah
we're filming it now are some of these
changes going to trickle over there we
switch it up all the time
on the show you know we are a roomful of
gay producers and we're very very
imaginative okay so we've got lots and
lots of tricks we were looking and
watching everything that's happening in
the world and we incorporate everything
into the show that's the beauty of drag
is that we can to sort of sample and
take bits and pieces from everything and
put it into our machine and by putting
it into a drag storyline it changes its
pH balance it changes everything into a
whole nother thing so there'll be lots
of surprises ooh I like that changes the
pH balance yeah now as far as all-stars
to goes who should we have our eye on
you should have your eye on me I'm the
queen to watch the real winner of every
season of RuPaul's Drag Race RuPaul